that was a great stop Carlson with a great pass
too now zis it rolls in front of the net taken
back and oh Terry is robbed and then Carlson
scores the penalty had expired it looked like
Anaheim was going to score three times and they
finally get a goal from the rookie Johnny kept
some pucks alive back at that blue line when it
looked like the Bruins were going to be able to
clear eventually no one seen to be able to find
the handle right on the doorstep but that was
Trevor zis again that lifted a stick yep kept the
puck alive and allowed Troy Terry to I don't know
if he kicked it on purpose or if it just banked
off his leg to Carlson with the Ducks of life
and they win the draw down low it's curled and
a clearing attempt by ly Holm hit Troy Terry
support comes from stro across the top of the
Zone he gives it to mnov bottom of the circle
Terry looks throws it in score Troy Terry ties the
game it was tipped in front only 14.7 seconds left
score two in the final 2 minutes of Regulation oh
you know what it hits Brad Maran stick and goes
up into the top corner you won't see it from this
angle but no chance forar the redirect is perfect
second of the season for Terry Mavish comes over
helps get the puck loose here's Carlson two-on-one
with McTavish great pass McTavish scores and the
ducks come all the way back to win an overtime
tonight in Boston what an amazing comeback John
you know what it took a bunch of big stops from
John Gibson at 3-1 to keep them in this game and
in the final couple of minutes and the overtime
the Ducks just had the the entire time and Leo
Carlson puts that puck in the perfect spot for
Mason McTavish and the celebration is on boy
these young kids man they can play Carlson will
get the primary assist he makes the pass over to
McTavish and he beats elmar and Anaheim with two
dramatic com from behind overtime victories to
open this road trip and they give Boston native
Greg Cronin a win in his hometown in his first
appearance at the TD Garden as an NHL head coach
well congratulations a great moment for Greg
Cronin no doubt butth boy what a moment for
this team you know they're playing one of the
best teams in the league and one of the best
teams of protecting a lead but they they just
stuck to it they won Puck battles and that to
me was the big key and Carlson just puts that
right into the Wheelhouse of M davish and he
goes five hole Mason's third of the year is the
fourth of the night for the Ducks and it's the
game winner and overtime victory in Boston
for Anaheim we're back with more after this